[Music]
all right so next up
please join me in welcoming brian lewis
we'll be talking about
parallel computing with r using for each
future and other packages
all right well uh yeah people are
shuffling in and out um
yeah first it goes without saying that
it's a huge privilege
for me to be able to hang out with so
many
cool and interesting people it's not i
normally don't get to hang out with cool
people
so i'd really like to thank joe and
hadley and jj and everyone at our studio
for making that
possible and can you all hear me okay
because i'm going to talk
really fast because i got a ton of
slides right right so
it really is a lot of slides so i'm not
loud so okay
can you turn it up just slightly so they
can hear me better guys
okay um
all right uh actually
wow it's crowded
all right let's begin so
you're writing some r code
or maybe you're working on an r package
and your package is a super big data
number crunching science package right
so you're really
really interested and worried about
performance of your code
and you need to study this so maybe you
pick up pat burns
excellent book the r inferno and you
learn a lot from this book
tons of performance tips about r and
lots of other interesting nuggets
about the r language but the book kind
of scares you a little bit so then you
move on to hadley's book
right and you learn even more about the
r language and in particular about
performance
and you also stroke your chin
thoughtfully as you ponder all those
donald knuth quotations in the book
right and after studying these things
for a long time
you've become expert in vectorization
and byte code compilization and all of
these things and finally you
you you with great anticipation you get
to run your package
and it runs really really slow
it's very very cute your package is
super cute but it's also super super
slow
right and then you remember oh wait i've
got rstudio and they've got all these
newfangled profiling tools that profits
and other things that help you look at
your r codes
visualize your r code see where it's
spending all this time so you load up
your your uh your package into
rstudio and you run profits and you look
at where you're spending all their time
in code and you notice
that your package is spending a lot of
time in these loop-like structures like
l-applies or maybe replicates or reduces
or maps
or or is it map which one is it yeah one
of those anyway
and and um and then and then it
and then it strikes you of course i
spent all this crazy amount of money on
my
super super fancy mac pro escalade which
has got a zillion cpu cores
and all those l apply loops that i'm
running are only using a single
cpu but of course this is r
and you realize there's a package for
that the parallel package right and it
even comes with r
right so of course this is this is what
i'll use so with renewed vigor you go
back into your package and you
you look at all your l applies and you
change all of the l applies to mikkelle
applies and you change all your maps to
mic maps
all the while you're thinking what if
mcdonald's sues for trademark
infringement you know i mean
simon urbanic is going to be in some
serious trouble right and
so uh anyway you get all this done and
finally you're ready to run your package
again and it's
it blows your mind it's running so fast
that your mac pro escalade is glowing
red hot it's ripping through your data
big science code really super fast
you've never seen our or even your mac
perform like this before it's fantastic
right
so you tell all your friends about it
you're so excited everybody wants to
use your package and so your friend
jared lander he calls you up and he's
excited about running your package
so you give your package to jared and of
course jared's using a windows laptop
and when he runs it it doesn't work
right you know
because windows right
and then you think oh yeah wait though
there's not
those parallel package functions not all
of them work on all the operating
systems especially windows so you tell
jared
you know that's not a problem jared i'll
just rip out some of my l applies and
i'll replace them with cluster whatever
applies right and i'll get it all to
work for you on your windows machine and
you do that and it works fine
meanwhile while you're working on that
your other friend
that's right you've only got two friends
your other friend george osterchov
he he's really excited about your
package too and he's got
of course he's got this super peda exit
computer in his garage down there in
tennessee somewhere in the appalachian
mountains and he wants to run it you
start talking about george and you're
excited to run it on such a big computer
but you realize you've got to run it
using
something called mpi because george says
real hpc
programmers use mpi you know whatever
but there's a package for that too right
there's this rmpi package so you start
rewriting your code again and you
and this is harder this time because
this is npi stuff is really tricky and
it's like it's taking a bit of wha
it's taking quite a bit of while and
meanwhile this is snowballing other
people are asking well what about this
what about this can i run it on that can
i run on that
and before long you're losing friends
and your family's pissed off at you
because you're spending all of your time
staring at an r studio console
maintaining like 50 versions of your
package for all these different parallel
distributed network uh runtime systems
right it's driving you crazy
and then you know you're neurotic right
so you start to get really worried about
this and you're like
what you know what if i lose friends
over this i might start losing sleep and
then maybe i would get depressed
i could lose my job that would probably
lead inevitably to a life of crime and
woe
and then finally you have a vision of
yourself as a crazy old person on a
street corner ranting and raving about
lazy evaluation dark
dark dark thoughts
this this is the situation we found
ourselves in
in 2008 and my friend and
at the time my colleague steve weston he
looked back
at this problem and he thought there's
there's got to be a better way a
different way
a different approach what if
package authors and code writers could
decide which
parts of their program can run in
parallel
and separately later the users of those
packages decide how
those uh codes should run in parallel
based on their circumstances and
available resources
this is the philosophy of for reach
and it's a philosophy it's a philosophy
shared by henrik's
much more recent future package and it's
a
it's a very very important point because
we abstract away
the uh implementation of a particular
parallel
portion of our code and leave that up to
the user to decide
at runtime how things should run now
back in 2008 steve
made the decision to to syntactically
structure for each
uh in the form of a for loop and because
back then steve was really
enamored of of list comprehensions and
set comprehensions and all these kinds
of haskelly things right he was really
into that
speaking of haskell you know you know
the reticulate package
and how beautifully it integrates python
with with r
it's lovely right have you used
reticulate wouldn't it be really cool if
somebody did that with
with r and haskell right and they could
call it rascal i would really like that
that would be that would be an excellent
package but but back to for each
um despite its for-loop syntax
um 4-h really kind of works like a
reduce of a map and let's make that
concrete by looking at a really kind of
simple contrived example here's a for
each
loop and i'll explain each part um for
each is a function
and these iteration variables i and j
and the blue circle they
they kind of play the role of any old
iterator variable in a regular old for
loop
um and and we can supply a reduction
function
using this dot combine argument and that
can be any function you want of two or
more arguments
and in this case i'm just using the r
bind function and then in the purple
circle there's just a regular old r
expression it could be any r expression
you want and it can use those iterator
variables and in our case we're just
going to run over the unique values of i
and j each iteration of the loop is
going to produce a single row data frame
and we'll pass it to r bind
and if we run but wait there's this
weird mysterious
operator dupar that takes like a
function call on one side and
our expression on the other it's kind of
bizarre if we run this
well big surprise you know we have two
loop iterations each one
emits a single row of a data frame
they're passed into our bind
and our ultimate output is a two-row
data frame rocket science
so uh but we also get this interesting
warning message from dupar
and that's dupar telling us look man
you know you didn't tell me that you
could run it in parallel or
or you wanted to run it in parallel so
just so you know this was one
run on a plain old sequential r session
and that's what dupar does that strange
operator is effectively
the api of the for each package it's the
glue
that takes your r uh
statements and variables and puts them
together with
with various ways to run those things in
parallel like mpi
or whatever and that that's the
abstraction layer the the api
and so here's an example of that a user
then
can register a particular parallel
adapter package in this case do parallel
with this registration function and
dupar sees that through a hidden global
variable somewhere
and now the loop without changing the
code in any way
runs and gives you the same answer but
this time it's run in parallel in in
this example
two separate r processes were started
for each loop iteration
their output was combined through the r
bind function to give you the same
the same result that's the philosophy of
for each and the future package
in a nutshell thanks to henrik's
amazing work uh the future package
um is is like a new extension of this
idea
then it doesn't it just doesn't give you
any
there's no unlike for each where you
have a you know
a very opinionated syntactical structure
of a for loop
future package lets you do things like
this using any type of r
syntax that you want you can use regular
old for loops l applies maps
the other map replicate no loop at all
you can do anything you want to do
and the cool thing is the both the
future package and the for each package
use magic
they do they auto magically
detect and make sure that lexically
scoped r
objects are available to the worker
processes so in this case
it's the same loop we were running
before except notice there's this k
variable at the top that's not defined
within the body the expression that's in
the loop
and for each and do par smart enough to
identify that
and say wait a minute that that worker
process is going to need that value i
make sure that all that it has it
uh even though it's defined lexic in a
lexical scope
and sure enough it works and that'll
work if you're running it on the same
computer or if you're running across
your departmental network
or if you're using aws to run it across
the country or even if you're running on
another planet right it'll all just work
magically it's really really quite
amazing
there are a few other kind of
interesting things about the for each
package that are more esoteric
you can compose two for each loops
together with a composition operator
then that produces a
a third for each loop and that can be
really useful for
nested parallelism to make it work
actually in a more predictable way and
going back to the haskily ideas you can
compose a for each loop with kind of a
predicate filtering operation to produce
the when function in this case to
produce a set comprehension a very
haskelly kind of thing
um and steve was very much into those
ideas
um see where we at now again thanks to
this amazing
guy right here who's going to talk about
the future package and just in the very
next talk so you all should stick around
future works interoperably with 4-h
through the do future
parallel adapter package as do a number
of other older
parallel adapters that are listed there
before this talk i went and updated
some that i haven't i've been neglecting
for a while the do redis and do mpi
uh mpi and redis back-ends for for each
are recently updated and they're either
on cran now or they're
kind of pending uh into cran and i've
got a
i started writing kind of hacking
together a guide uh
to explain the internal for each to
prospective
uh parallel adapter authors if you want
to write your own parallel adapter to
connect your super duper fancy
you know whatever multi-gpu computer
thing you can do that and
there's a little guy there that helps
walk you through what what you know how
to dot the eyes and cross a t's
now i have to say i i i believe that
this is
a vitally important addition to
the r software ecosystem it really fills
a gap or it filled back in 2009 when we
introduced it it filled a gap
that was really missing in our and it's
been
it's been very important and and that's
why i've tried
to support it a little bit in a limited
capacity here and there over the years
but you don't have to take my word for
that
all you need to do is go on cran and uh
look at the for each page and you can
see
all of these r packages that either
depend
explicitly or implicitly on for each and
there's a lot of them
right so there's a huge impact from this
software
and that's that's really makes me quite
happy
because as some of you know so we lost
steve last summer he passed away
sadly and but he didn't right his ideas
are were as vital today to the our
software ecosystem and spawning new work
by new people as they were you know 10
years ago
so i think it's a testament to steve's
vision how important this
uh this work was and this has been kind
of a weird
lightning introduction to an abstraction
layer for parallel computing i know
i didn't go very deep into things but
i'm going to conclude this talk because
i don't want to burden you with all of
these
super technical details i'll leave that
to henrik
but i'd like to conclude the talk in
kind of a weird
character characteristically weird way
right i'll i'll paraphrase
uh the great labor organizer and folk
singer steve was also into folk music
joe hill
and on joe's deathbed he said don't
mourn don't mourn my passing
parallel well he didn't say parallelized
but steve would have said parallel lies
so
that's all i have for you thank you very
[Applause]
much
thank you so much brian yeah we have we
have a number of minutes left so
uh yeah it was pretty quick yeah if you
want to ask any more questions we've got
some room on slido
here so as the author of this package
i'm kind of curious about
your answer what do you think about the
fur package as the combination of per
and future uh yeah i think so so
the functional concepts uh
i mean you can see me i mentioned in
haskell right so so you know having
uh side effect free operations whenever
possible
that are promoted by things like the
pure package um
are important and they're in fact
essential
for embarrassingly parallel style
mapreduce computation that we get with
with future and and with for reach so i
think you know it's a natural fit
actually that's really what i have to
say about it
um one other question here so this is
just kind of technical but how do we
assign the number of cores to be used
yeah that's up to the the the parallel
adapter code i mean that's the point at
runtime the user can make a decision
so if you're just using the rs native
parallel package you would supply
a number when you say register i had
that slide up there that said register
do parallel and if you just put a number
in there that's the number of cores it's
going to use
and and you know that's of course
depends if you're using an mpi backend
you've got a different convention or if
you're using redis or one of these other
job queuing systems or whatever
they all have slightly different
conventions with dealing
how the work is going to be run right
yeah
so a couple more just popped in
are there any recommendations about
debugging when using parallel computing
well that's a great question actually
yeah it's a
it's challenging right parallel
distributed computing and parallel
computing in general is nightmarishly
complicated to debug um and and
there are uh yeah there are the in both
uh the future work and in for each there
are various tricks that you can use
to help debug your code there's an
option in for each to
uh stop on the first error that's
encountered on any worker
process anywhere and throw that error in
the r session that's its
default but you can also just pass the
errors as they come
so if you're getting lots of errors in
your iterate loop iterations you can
just see all of them
to see what's happening and you can also
this is probably
not advisable but you can also ignore
errors and depending on the
the the back ends the the the kind of
adapter packages
the ones that that work with the
standard are
parallel package and mc packages they
don't do so well at
debugging but uh some of the other
parallel adapters
uh have provisions in them for logging
and maintaining
uh logs to you know just regular r
connections so you can direct
logs to files on the backend workers and
inspect those
after um you know
or just or or if you have the ability to
look at standard error standard out you
can you can actually
look at those as it's running on the on
the other workers too to help debug but
it's still
tricky and i'm sure this guy's going to
have a lot more to say about or do you
have more to say about henrik i don't
know it's hard right it's hard
maybe i'm sorry i didn't mean to put any
pressure on you there
um okay so i think we still have some
more time um so i had a question and if
max [ __ ] is in here i'm sure he'd be
proud of me for asking yeah there's my
um so he and i are really interested in
getting
messages kind of back in real time like
any warnings or error messages coming
back in real time from your workers like
is that even possible depending on well
in
i don't know about future in 4-h you can
throw an error
and that's coming back in real time if
you pass the errors through right so so
that that would be the only way to do
that right now
on any in in for each in an abstract way
uh like warnings and messages maybe
where it's still continuing to run like
that didn't stop yeah
no yeah that's a great question and i
don't know of any facility for doing
that that would be
you'd need some extra communication
channel off the main
channel to to send that information
through you could do it through files
but you know you may not have access to
files
you know if they're running on another
planet right maybe you can't get those
right so uh i don't know that's a it's a
tricky one max
i figured you would ask something tricky
like that
okay let's thank brian one more time
thank y'all
[Music]